Lucy this is Lucy and douglas douglas oh
they're so friendly oh they're such good
dog a mom like you oh oh he's like Mommy
yeah I know and you also love your dogs
I do love my dogs Elvis and essel elv oh
my God this is this is my dream come
true come on guys sorry ducky will they
jump Lucy come here come here come on up
up up there we go oh my God this is me
help you
playy yeah there we go that's it I love
this so much
um I I do I have two dogs Elvis and
Ethel who are multi poos and I am I hear
they're your life too they're my entire
oh there they are oh my God aren they oh
no look at what are you really doing if
you don't have cowboy boots for your
dogs like that the best feeling in the
world is coming home to them